- [Gary] If i gave up
producing content at the
same time that most
of you give up,
all the greatest things
that have happened
to me professionally
would not be happening.
The Monday Rant video
was reverse engineered.
Take a step back and think
about how awesome
it actually is.
I just knew that people
would want to watch it.
That's what I also think is
is gonna happen here.
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk,
director of operations
here at Wine Library
and WineLibrary.com
and I am very proud to launch
what we think is
the first video wine blog.
If you want this,
if you want bling bling,
if you want to buy the Jets,
if you want to do shit, work.
That's how you get it.
I know that I'm built to win
when it comes to business.
I always win.
I'm gonna win.
Snapchat is a communication
funnel that for those
nine seconds while
you're holding it
you actually have
to pay attention.
I feel like I've got the
team now in place
to actually do this more often.
So, here we go.
I fully, fully 100,000%
with no hedge
do not believe that you can
teach entrepreneurship.
Right? So, that's awkward.
You coulda ended up
being a bus, a tree.
I just don't get the mentality
of being head down, sad.
I'm not some great philosopher.
This is simple shit.
One at-bat.
I'm scared that you don't
realize that you're entering the
greatest five-year
window of your life.
I just don't
understand why people
relegate in to losing mentality
and just thinking they can't.
There's plenty of time,
get shit done.
You're gonna die.
Yeah, that's inspiration.
- Do something about it.
So, please my friends
understand that you've
got to keep creating.
Literally one piece of content
can change your game,
can change your outcome.
If I gave up what most
of you usually give up
then I too would not
have any of the business
success that you guys
all see now.
Keep creating.
(light music)